الجويه
اثناء استقبال حكومه 30 ديسمبر يعني قد
دمرت صاله كبار الضيوف وجزء كبير من صاله
المغادره تم اعادتها بالكامل بحوالي يمكن
اثنين مليون دولار كذلك اعاده تاهيل ساحه
وقوف الطائرات
استعدوا البرنامج السعودي لتنشيد المرحله
الثالثه والتي ستخصص لتاهيل المدرج
الرئيسي وتحديث انظمه الملاحه والجاهزيه
التشغيليه والنواحي التقنيه لتواكب
المطارات الدوليه بما يمكن مطار عدن من
استقبال عدد اكبر من الرحلات في المستقبل
المرحله الثالثه الذي سوف تحتوي
المدرج الهبوط والاغلاق الذي هو مبرر بشكل
كبير بالاضافه الى الاجهزه الملاحيه
الهبوط الالي وغيرها من الاجزاء الملاحيه
الذي تحصل الهبوط والاقلاع في مطار عدن
الدولي هذا المطر وقد تعرض لتدمير كامل
على يد الميليشيات الحوثيه التي سيطرت
عليه لاربعه اشهر عام 2015
وبعد تحرير عدم تولى البرنامج السعودي
لاعاده اعمار اليمن مهمه اعاده تاهيل
المطار الذي يعد الشريان الرئيسي الذي
يربط اليمن بباقي دول العالم ياتي مشروع
اعاده تاهيل مطار عدن الدولي ضمن 229
مشروع مبادره تنمويه نفذها البرنامج
السعودي لتنميه اعمار اليمن في شتى
المحافظات اليمنيه طبعا المشروع اعاده
تاهيل مطار عدن الدولي تم الانتهاء ولله
الحمد من المرحله الاولى والثانيه
وسيتم الاستئناف ان شاء الله او بدا
الاستئناف في المرحله الثالثه والاخيره
والتي تضمن اعاده تاهيل المدرج الرئيسي
بالاضافه الى توفير
وتركيب الاجهزه الملاحيه
لواكب مطار عدن الدولي ان شاء الله
المطارات العالميه
كان تاهيل مطار عدن الدولي واحده من
اولويات البرنامج السعودي لاعاده اعمار
اليمن لما للمطار اهميه لعدم وباقي
المحافظات اليمنيه حيث ان هذا المطار هو
الشريان الرئيس الذي يربط البلاد بالعالم
الخارجي ردفان دبيس العربيه عددا
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات